[Music]
what do you think of when you hear the
words violence prevention seriously take
a second and think about that many of
you are probably thinking law
enforcement right well my hope is that
by the end of this talk healthcare comes
into your mind just as quickly as law
enforcement probably did if not even
faster so one question that some folks
often ask is why is violence so common
violence is a pretty widely agreed-upon
societal veiss we all know it's bad and
yet it's everywhere according to the
FBI's Uniform Crime reporting program in
2016
there are over 1.2 million violent
crimes committed in the u.s. over 17,000
of these resulted in deaths now that's
the size of the entire student
population here at Stanford so it's a
fair question why is violence so come
let me try and explain with the personal
story when I was 12 I moved into the
Sumner housing projects of Brooklyn New
York I was actually really excited about
this because there was a basketball
court right in front of my new apartment
I've been playing basketball for a while
and still wasn't very good but you see
all that would change now because I
could practice on this court
I actually remember going up to all my
friends and saying hey guys give me
about a year practice and I'm dunking on
everybody I was uh pretty Delusion with
back then yeah so one day I was out
there on the court shooting around and
as I said it wasn't very good so most of
those shots miss and on one of the
misses the ball bounced off the rim and
rolled to the side of the park another
kid picks it up and walks off so I run
up to him and say hey man hey that's uh
that's my ball and he keeps on walking
and before I know it I'm surrounded by
about 20 other kids all with their fists
clenched and eyebrows furrow and they
were yelling yelling yo yo what you
doing here snow what you doing here who
you with
I was a fresh-faced clueless
twelve-year-old kid I didn't know what
to say
I got beat up pretty badly that day and
as I eventually managed to push my way
out of the crowd of sneakers and fisting
ran home eyes full of tears I thought
the next time something like this
happens I need to have something to say
Who am I with who can defend me here and
that's how you end up befriended some
pretty sketchy characters that introduce
you to gangs guns and before you know it
you've been fully initiated into the
vicious cycle of violence I was lucky in
that I have an incredible month whenever
I screwed up she would put me in my
place it's funny really I'm a lot taller
than my mom didn't matter she would
stand up on top of a chair she had to
look down at me screaming at the top of
her lungs to make sure that I stayed on
the straight and narrow but
unfortunately there are a lot of other
folks in these kinds of communities that
don't have that influence and thus we
end up with this huge issue of violence
now once you ought to imagine yourselves
growing up in Sumner right along with me
to help you do that let's paint a
picture Sumner is actually a really
lively neighborhood there are tons of
beautiful parks and trees little kids
running around as they play on pretty
much every block now there is loud music
always blasting from someone's window
behind you
barbecues here you're surrounded by a
whole lot of happiness but also a whole
lot of violence growing up in Sumner you
saw gangs drugs fighting shooting
constant policing the whole night now
imagine the inevitable happens and
you get shot what happens next
someone calls 9 1 1 an ambulance rushes
down picks you up and brings you to the
nearest emergency department there
you're treated stabilized and thankfully
recovering in your hospital bed what do
you see around you all kinds of tubes
sticking in and out of your body
loud beeping sounds that never seem to
stop unfamiliar faces in these bright
white coats coming in and out and in and
out of your room what's going through
your mind in this moment probably
something like wow I almost died today I
may have never seen my parents siblings
boyfriend/girlfriend anyone again I
can't go back to this life someone
anyone help and in that moment you are
probably more receptive to intervention
than you've ever been before but that's
also keep in mind a huge window of
opportunity that law enforcement just
doesn't have but unfortunately in many
instances these patients are treated and
then sent right back to the same violent
environment that spawned those injuries
in the first place
with no means of preventing recurrence
so you may be asking ok but what can we
actually do for these folks inside of a
hospital well a lot actually I'm here at
Stanford for an MBA but I'm also a
fourth year medical student at Harvard
while there I worked with the violence
recovery program or the VRP at the
Brigham and Women's Hospital the VRP is
a hospital-based violence prevention
program that targets patients who are
victims and perpetrators of violence and
provides the resources necessary to stop
them from coming back to the hospital
now at the VRP this mainly took the form
of counseling but our counselors were
unique in that they each had their own
personal experiences with violence so
often that let me add that that was in
the very same neighborhoods that these
patients were from so whereas more
traditional counselors might have been
trained at graduate program these folks
are trained by life and that enabled
them to establish a much more personal
connection
with our patience but it doesn't need to
end there one can imagine also including
things like housing relocation job
training legal support educational
support really any number of services
that would be the most effective for a
given patient and the beautiful thing is
that these services often already exist
in the communities that these patients
are from and thus all a hospital based
program would need to do would be to
connect these patients to these services
during this window of opportunity
imagine the impact this could have if
skilled now there are a number of
similar programs across the country and
they're all housed under a larger
umbrella organization known as the
national network for hospital based
violence intervention programs or the
nnh VIP there are about 32 programs
within this network and they're all
doing great work but again just 32
programs there are far more than 32
hospitals in this country and even more
communities that struggle with violence
violence is a tremendous issue according
to the CDC violence is listed as the
second and third leading causes of death
among American youth second being
suicide and third homicide now that
place is it higher than any of the more
traditional medical disorders you can
probably think of cancer heart disease
diabetes all of that so for something
that has such a large impact on the
health and mortality of patients I find
it imperative that we in health care
address this so I want to ask you all to
consider three things and before I say
that I just want to stress this point
that violence is a public health issue
and we can't leave it to law enforcement
to deal with all alone so for those
three things what if you're a clinician
in the audience or watching online if
you work in a hospital that serves
communities struggling with violence
consider starting your own violence
prevention program it could go a long
way in improving the overall health of
your patient population to
if you're not a clinician maybe no one
or a hospital administrator a
policymaker really any decision-maker in
this space use those connections and
convince those folks to try and help
create more of these programs and three
if you're not a clinician and don't know
any decision-makers that's okay too at
the very least think back to the
question that we started this talk with
what do you think of when you hear the
words violence prevention I hope that
now you can appreciate the impact that
healthcare can have in reducing violence
and the next time you talk about
violence prevention I hope that
healthcare is one of the first things
that comes into your mind thank you
[Applause]
[Music]